what was the journey from the graphic
novel to the film how much time between
when you discovered it and you wanted to
make a film and it was 2005 I I met that
graphic novel in the shop and I was so
fascinated by that and I made my mind
yeah I have to make the movie with this
graphic novel 2005 but at the time I was
in the pre-production of the host my
previous movie and also 2000 Kamiya
something in Peru run yak so we'll head
in my hands and tears of mad battle
reticulum so he already promised
comedian to work on mother with her okay
Iook so groggy man until I get the money
what Kaymer aku motto 300 miles Hanyu
and hydroponic Joe and Sal when you're
challenging me pan corners and Santiago
so the rights were purchased but he had
to make the host and yet to make mother
before that so and 2010 I loved her
script and 2011 quite long
pre-production and pre-prep and 2012 we
shoot the movie in Czech Republic in a
big sound stage in in Prague
Danny Kaye de chalma cherub and rage on
America could you tell him Drasil so
this is a train movie and we had to make
the train that was really hard
more we have a great production to China
and great special effects team but
anyway the chimbly dantana right-hander
Marco ing Amana Tom samyama at the
Madison and made into a jig in and said
set room GJ asian and Korean Q&A chat or
Oregon Jake Church embodiment Rahzel
okay she checked her scepter in Jake
cetera got embody Orinoco suture room
chicken and go John later Cokie so Han
hecho nada permanent shoot arrows at
calm jiguro ki jagah
crazy crew ki j JH and the community
came man Chris a coffee so Han Horizonte
checked up on Manama Molly me gonna get
to how pretty so you know Gimbels from
when they make plain movies or submarine
movies they they build the sets on top
of a moving gimbal it's basically a
moving set this is probably one of the
first times that a trained gimbal was
created and all the sets were on top and
there was you know it's really to make
the mimic the movement of a real train
and if you're shooting on that all day
you get really carsick
it's a canary Taryn go to handsome areas
of canary mantra and they NJ Concannon
Connie Tom oh yes I need to knew my
needle and beautification Jim
agriculture necessary and come oh yes I
know three person she just a condiment
random vehicle lodging here more pensive
is a pecan and chickadee eminent again
I'm Chun LAN yes Anna aunty Nica Google
Chris Evans civic each arrow contour and
again Iike you cannot to get me around
and I'll go check our nation's over you
know my sequences from somewhere okay
scenario suitable to call a junkie
Apache wickiup such on so in total we
built 26 train cars and each one is very
expensive so he had to decide early on
which train cars to build in which to
shoot it wasn't as if he had the budget
to shoot whatever he wanted and figure
out what to use in post-production also
the movie is adjourned
for Chris Evans to get to the front of
the Train so all the the sections of
cars and which comes before what and
what comes after was very critical and
precisely determined because it really
was the narrative structure I also want
to ask a question about family because a
lot of your films deal with the
relationships between family I mean in
your very first film barking dogs never
bite you have a couple who's about to
have a child in obviously mother you
have a mother and her let's say complex
relationship with her son and in the
host you similarly to this film you kind
of have well in that film we actually
have an actual family that has to go
through a traumatic situation and sort
of the way it impacts their
relationships and in this film I feel
like you play a lot with the notion of
family and you know children getting
separated from their parents and people
having almost like father like roles and
you know the father of the train I guess
my question is what is it about you and
family's cattle given a genome Oh once
again autonomy Pedro Mota Pancho guru
gotcha parent electro-man a rotten
captain comes on transit on ganja gabato
cotton comes on and emotional setting I
see cohesion and gay Haggadah and
honking
character scenarios to take etiquette
etiquette all those and again I didn't
go at all so just the idea family it's a
universal thing all over the world and
it helps set the tone and it's a shared
emotion with everybody so everyone can
relate to it so he thinks about that
when he's writing it just automatically
kind of comes into the picture
yo Mohammed katoki Octavia Spencer and
ammonia are three one
c'mon erotica doctrina whatta man take
some Gong Wu Chi Yong Yong namgoong
minsu Tariana turn include Puyo
conjugate a middle Jaime toes air kisses
sir
so you see several families in the movie
Octavia Spencer and her son but really
the father-daughter relationship with
song kang-ho who plays the character of
lamb and his daughter
Yona that was his most interesting about
Zidane daddy makishima hyung kid throw
go to Hannah hit him he sent home for
new organizing a quick action with an
Igor :
yes so it's the father and daughter do
drugs together and it's sort of bizarre
but that's not really the point
it's a tonin sci-fi a gig on on Kim a
sci-fi young mother Manton and god
Nicole already got to him as a poem God
made egg and chrome going gotta take a
Mobius a keg in Goku Hong then more
fantastic atomizer Sheeran take a
breather - enjoy your garden
yeah gear on and go Karen gasps I pay oh
my amiga oka
so tomb krom'gar hibaldo wooden ssl so
you know just speaking of spot sci-fi
and making a sci-fi and watching sci-fi
films the joy is you know not just in
it's about the future and it's a
fantastic world but it's really about
our world today and how we live and
ourselves and that's kind of the fun of
it